something is happening in the comedy
world
world right now around this whole cancel
culture situation and comedians being on
the front lines of it
and no one
more on the front lines than mr dave
chappelle and his new comedy special
if you young comics
it's just that if someone like dave
chappelle
is regardless of how you feel about what
he says
if a comedian like dave chappelle
is still
under this much scrutiny like i mean the
special isn't that old but i mean it was
last year and a lot has happened and a
lot is currently happening and the fact
that he is now like
still having to release an entire
special basically kind of
inspired by this you know if dave
chappelle's having to tread lightly then
it's like comedians you know
think before you tweet i would say
yeah
yeah i mean and i think it's all about
do you want the words that you were
saying to be sort of what is attached to
you like forever
do you mean like the internet does not
go away right i mean we got the example
of shane gillis who
hadn't really tweeted anything um for a
while he was up for snl and next thing
you know they found something old that
he put out
and it basically got him in essence
didn't get him a gig on
snl
but he's doing fine now but it didn't
get him the gig that he was
going at but i mean also you know i
can't deny the boy he he monetized that
too because he definitely turned that
ship around and he's doing fine now
um
but it's definitely like you know it's
i say the young comics heed the warning
of knowing that anything and everything
you do say
and you put out on social media
does have not only a shelf life but also
it can come back to
bite you
yep in a year in a decade like you just
you know kevin hart another example he
was about to host the oscars
and then
they went deep in your boys archive
found some like homophobic tweets and
such and then
he's not hosting the oscars you know so
and this is at a very early level in
your careers of like okay we're supposed
to be creating a lot of content and we
got to get out there and we got to build
a following and all of that
and that is part of the hustle but be
mindful of what you're posting and i
would especially early i would focus on
quality
over quantity like you really want to
have something worth sharing because you
got to think
if it goes viral
when you post something think would i
want this to go viral what i want to be
known for this what i want what will
this look like in five years in 10 years
because there's real
business implications i mean we talked
about shane gillis we talked about kevin
hart dave chappelle
uh andrew schultz another example of
someone very controversial and he
actually ended up having to buy back his
most recent comedy special due to
controversial material on the special
yeah
like
i mean and these are people these are
also people were saying like
dave chappelle andrew schultz arguably
the funniest people on the
top of the food chain tougher than the
food chain so when you see them doing
an abortion joke or you see them doing a
trans joke this is something we even
brought up
on the q a i did with mike binder when
he was talking about bill burr and how
he does these
risky topics
but he has spent over 30 years honing
the craft of comedy to be able to pull
these topics off so take that in mind
comedians it's like yes you want you
want to be the next billbury you want to
talk about these topics you'll get there
work hard keep writing performing you'll
get there my friends
but start with just like fundamental
facts about you and your life and your
experiences and then you can start to
weave in the controversy once you have a
very confident competence
of the craft of comedy this is not
something you just say
and then whatever
what you're saying is mattering now more
than ever like you're a comedian you're
on the front lines of free speech and
people are listening so do take what
you're posting and sharing and saying
seriously and not just as like a
throwaway of like oh maybe this will go
viral
yeah facts man i mean you said it best i
think
it's i usually do yeah it's usually
it's usually me that's bringing it home
there really
[Laughter]
um but yeah i mean i think it's just
important to know that
the art of comedy takes time
especially at that level and part of the
reason we practice and tell you guys
around you know everyone really around
going personal is
that's like
no one can argue with that this is your
own sort of personal take on things um
these are things that are happening to
you and like
the reason why it makes it so much i
mean there's a reason why jerry seinfeld
like comedy isn't the kind of comedy
that's
all over the place now because there was
a time when that was the type of comedy
that everyone did it was very
observational everyone did it it could
relate to absolutely anyone and everyone
but jerry seinfeld is kind of one in a
million there's not a lot of people that
are doing jerry seinfeld like comedy and
what's happened is that just our culture
and sort of our ego not our egos but
like the ecosystem has kind of changed
so people just aren't into that what
people are into as you can tell as you
guys are seeing from social media comedy
and the netflix's it's personal yeah
people are coming out and talking about
you know you know we've done a couple of
comedy specials the ali sadiq special
was like personal the earthquake show
was personal um
the taylor thompson special
personal you mean like all but those
were heat like those were solid specials
but they were very very personal
but man those guys are like they're such
good writers
but they got to that point off of
practice
a lot of practice so be careful what be
careful what you post out there my
friends you know it's uh because you
never know
what when you post something just ask
what i want this what i want to be known
for this forever